on se souvient de l'annnonce de ce texte
par le premier ministre et le message
était simple il faut accélérer la
vaccination est donc on va transformer
le pass and i ter en panne vaccinale est
sûre cet objectif premier nous sommes
d'accord et c'est parce que nous sommes
d'accord que nous avons discuté de ce
texte est qu'en première lecture
constatant que un ensemble de
dispositifs visant à encadrer au mieux
cet outil du pass vaccinale qui nous
satisfait pas vraiment mais enfin bon le
cadrage été correct et bien que la
valeur principe yale qui est celle de
l'obligation vaccinale universel n'y
soit pas
comme nous sommes soucieux de l'intérêt
général nous avons effectivement voté
pour ce texte
mais je dois dire que sa trajectoire me
fait penser à ces volatiles qui n'ont
plus peut-être qu'ils partent droit puis
convoi zigzaguer et puis ça fait c
est vraiment on a un texte maintenant
qui a perdu sa cohérence et jusqu'à oui
monsieur le rapporteur on ne peut
qu'être étonné qu'un qu'une disposition
que vous avez fait mettre en première
lecture
vous foyer contraint de vous prononcer
contre en seconde lecture je pense que
c'est l'illustration des errements de ce
texte et on peut pas y voir la recherche
d'un vote conforme avec l'assemblée
nationale puisqu'il n'y a pas de vote
conforme et donc nous ne comprenons plus
les français ne comprendront pas non
seulement ce texte est inadaptée à la
situation actuelle mais ne se projettent
pas dans le temps et donc pour toutes
ces raisons effectivement nous ne
mènerons pas nos voix à ceux qui sont
opposés à la vaccination
nous ne feront pas obstacle
la personne et votre complexe
calcination mais nous ne pourrons pas
voter ce texte
[Musique]